president biden and vice president
harris are headed to atlanta today to
focus on voting rights and they're
working to pass federal voting rights
legislation by martin luther king jr day
that is less than a week from right now
ed o'keefe is in atlanta for us ahead of
the speeches ed good morning it's not
going to be easy to pass this
legislation is it
no it isn't tony good morning the
president and vice president will start
their day in atlanta here at ebenezer
baptist church where dr martin luther
king jr once served as co-pastor from
here they'll head across town to rally
democrats for new voting rights
legislation but here in georgia critics
say that on this issue the president
isn't moving fast enough
we haven't seen the type of leadership
that we need to see from from president
biden cliff albright is co-founder of
the black voters matter fund part of a
coalition of georgia groups that say
president biden shouldn't come to
atlanta without concrete plans to pass
voting rights legislation what we really
want to see given that he came down here
is that he's got a iron-clad deal in
place anything short of that is really
going to be disappointing the biden
administration is pushing to pass two
new voting rights bills and the white
house says the president today will call
upcoming votes on them a turning point
in the nation in his speech mr biden
will vow to defend your right to vote
and our democracy and will put pressure
on the senate to act the first bill
would establish national election
standards by requiring all 50 states to
offer at least two weeks of early voting
no excuse vote by mail options for every
voter a national voter id standard and
same-day voting registration republicans
generally oppose the bill they also want
same-day registration
and that's just you know very difficult
for any election official to manage and
i think that undermines trust in
elections the second bill would update
the 1965 voting rights act and force
states with a history of discrimination
to clear any potential changes to
election laws with the justice
department republican senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell says the bill
overreaches this is a bill to turn the
partisan attorney general into a
national election czar
so with no republican support the voting
rights legislation can't survive a
filibuster vote that means any debate
over voting rights is first going to be
about potentially changing senate rules
the white house says the president today
will reiterate support for changing the
rules by allowing bills to pass with a
simple majority i support making an
exception and voting rights for the
filibuster but albright says the
president needs to fight harder he's got
to give
complete unequivocal support not support
demand and call for filibuster reform
well uh sounds like that's what's going
to be said by the president today we'll
see and then there's the issue of
getting all democrats on board adding
pressure to the president some members
of dr king's family have said the nation
should not celebrate mlk day next monday
unless congress passes that voting
rights legislation
gail
oh throwing down the gauntlet a lot of
frustration in georgia thank you very
much ed